much of my identity in life now is
defined by loving science and I would
call myself a scientist I'm doing a PhD
and a lot of the opportunities that I've
had in life whether it's travelling or
anything else have been through science
and I feel like I've done quite well in
it I didn't always want to be a
scientist and I've sort of been
wondering how I ended up here
I definitely as a child didn't have any
particular desire to enter science or
any other academic field I think maybe
up to the ages of like 1415 I had just
no concept of even the idea of being a
scientist if you'd asked me back then
what I would do I probably would have
just said something like be a
hairdresser like that's the only sort of
career that I even had seen or thought
of I just because my parents weren't
scientists and I didn't really know any
scientists in my real life it was a very
alien idea for me at that stage so in
wandering this and wondering how I
became a scientist actually called my
mum and I asked her like why she thinks
I ended up loving science so much and
the thing that she said to me on the
phone was just that when I was a kid she
let me explore anything that I was
interested in so I do remember doing
lots of sort of after school activities
and clubs and none of them were science
related they would have been art or
music classes or like Bill guides and I
can take a things like that so I
definitely had a life that was full of
lots of different experiences and I had
this feeling that I could just if I was
interested in something I could pursue
it and I definitely had a lot of
interests my mom never directly bought
me like science books or something and
gave them to me and he said you read
this I like I want you to be a scientist
or she never really bought me those sort
of toys I see now for kids that are very
science learning back
but what she did do was make me feel
like for me anything was possible any
career that I wanted to do I felt like
she would have been supportive of it and
that goes for my whole family as well so
I think when that with that mindset when
I got a little bit older and I started
reading about you know real issues in
the world and real mysteries and I would
see documentaries and people will be
talking about space and the mysteries of
the universe and dark matter and all
these unsolved problems that people
wanted to figure out I always had this
idea that well why can't I be the one to
try and figure them out I really did
feel like for me anything was possible
so yeah when I saw problems in science
it wasn't that they were classed as
science that wasn't the reason I wanted
to pursue them I just felt like my
personality wanted to pursue problems
that were difficult and nothing really
felt out of my reach I have two brothers
who didn't end up going into science and
you know they had exactly the same
parenting as I did so I I don't even
think you can really ever make a child
into a scientist I think you know some
will really like science and some will
like other things you can't really give
your child any certain passion I think
that's the number-one thing is that you
just have to let them be who I think
they're going to be and I think the best
you can do is give them that sense that
for them anything is possible and that
they can pursue whatever they want and
that they will have support around them
doing that I definitely had a lot of
support and I think that's all you
really need to be a scientist is that
idea that you can actually tackle these
big problems science is something that
attracts people who want to work on some
of the biggest issues people that aren't
content with just saying there are all
these things we don't know and I'm okay
with not knowing scientists really want
to actually find out these
curious things about the world around us
and all they really need to be equipped
with is that idea that we can make a
change in the world and that we can
figure things out nothing is set in
stone and each of us sort of has the
ability and the creativity to make those
changes I know some people even some
friends of mine from school who had
parents who were sort of quite academic
and they actually did actively put
effort into trying to make their kids
pursue science or any other particular
topic whether it's medicine or law as
well and actually those people that I
know didn't end up pursuing what their
parents wanted them to in the end so you
know I actually think the essence here
is to not try too hard if you're trying
to actively force someone to have an
interest in something it would probably
backfire and the opposite would be true
I even think you know some of those
efforts could be detrimental in terms of
science and the way like maybe if I had
been more exposed to like little science
experiments that they make for kids and
I see selling in stores now maybe I
would have had a skewed idea that
science is just mixing chemicals and
making a volcano like a baking soda
volcano maybe I would have thought more
that science was just that stereotypical
white lab coat mixing things and seeing
action happen from that because to me I
don't really find those sort of science
experiments interesting and I never did
I never found the baking soda volcano
interesting at all the only science ever
found interesting was the very abstract
ideas the maths and the physics and
cosmology and things like that so I'm
sort of glad I wasn't exposed to any
particular stereotype of science that
had been you know generically made for
kids because I was able to jump straight
to some of that more advanced science
and think actually this is really cool
I'm glad I'm just meeting it in this
natural awesome form so those are sort
of my thoughts I hope they make sense in
essence if you're trying to make someone
be interested in science don't try too
hard
you can't mold people to be what you
want them to be and if you know someone
that you want to be like more curious or
something like that just encourage them
in a way that makes them feel that
anything is possible that they can
explore things and that they are capable
of researching ideas because they don't
need to just believe what other people
tell them they can go out and find
evidence and find facts for themselves